the regulations are becoming much
clearer in Europe and we're responding
to that challenge it's a great
opportunity for us to do a pull forward
our overall 2030 vision as a global
company is zero emissions of carbon
dioxide we see Europe challenging the
industry much more on how to deliver
that but we believe with the combination
of our hybrid technology and our battery
electric vehicles we can deliver on that
yeah and that's the point isn't it
you're talking about electrification but
a lot of these models are going to be
hybrid so you're not really coming off
petrol and diesel are you our hybrid
system is quite unique in the fact that
it runs in three modes so it runs in a
evie mode for most of the time and a
high speed it moves the engine into
direct charging so it's a self charging
hybrid which gives the customer the
opportunity to transition as well
towards a better electrified powertrain
and I think it's important that this
transition is managed so the customers
come with us in terms of that journey
tell me what you think are the
challenges faced by towns and cities if
the majority of vehicles on the road are
electric ones we announced a while ago
in Geneva that we've got partnerships
with companies like you Patricia T and
Mike sir about how we can optimize the
supply of electricity both in terms of
the ability to bide at a really good
price and at a smart timing but also
able to actually integrate smart
charging facilities on Street which
obviously with a car like the Honda II
which is an urban evey customers are
more likely going to be living in cities
they're going to be parking in public
areas and with yuba tricity we have a
great partnership enabling customers to
access electricity how much do the new
EU Japan free trade deal influences
decision to make the cars in Japan so we
have a very big global manufacturing
footprint today we're looking at the
electrification journey and we're
optimizing our resources in regions
where we have the scale the production
systems and the resources to do this so
we're looking at Japan for some of the
production but looking to Asia as well
so it's not just about the EPA that has
a very limited impact on our
decision-making but it's definitely not
about Swindon isn't it I mean what is so
lacking in this country that you can't
make the electric vehicles here so we've
spoken very openly about the decision
around souund and it's a very tough
decision
make electrification is challenging the
global car industry and particularly in
Europe and again we need to be
optimizing our capacity our resources
and our ability to engineer where we're
closest the markets have the biggest
volume and the biggest capacity and
that's really what we're doing and
lining and using the global opportunity
Honda has